hi
language learning is one of the most
enriching rewarding
satisfying activities we can engage in
if you're interested in this subject
please subscribe to my channel where i
talk about my experience in learning 15
languages
the most important task in language
learning in my opinion is the
acquisition of vocabulary words
if we have enough words we can make
sense of what we're reading or listening
to and we can somehow express ourselves
vocabulary is much more important than
grammar
the grammar you acquired gradually as
you become familiar with the language
with the words
but first of all you need the words so
how do we acquire vocabulary well i
think there's two sort of approaches
one is the deliberate study of
vocabulary by reading vocabulary lists
and trying to memorize them or doing
flash cards or these kinds of things
keeping handwritten lists
and the other is to learn through a lot
of exposure now
the strategy that you adopt will depend
on your personal preference and also on
in my view how much time you have if you
have a lot of time six seven hours a day
as i did when i was studying mandarin
chinese 45 years ago
then you can take an hour a day for the
deliberate study of vocabulary however
if you have one hour a day
and two thirds or three quarters of that
is time
which i call dead time in your car doing
tasks around the house walking the dog
then i suggest you don't try to
deliberately learn the vocabulary
and there's significant research which
shows that what they call block learning
or you take some material and try to
force yourself to learn it and review it
many many times and go through your for
example list of vocabulary or flash
cards over and over in the hope of
nailing that mastering it that is
relatively inefficient
and that interleaved learning
interleaving and i suggest you google
the term in other words where you come
across some information then you forget
it you go and look at some other
information you come back to that first
information so they're sort of
interleaving layers of different things
forgetting and relearning actually
enables you to learn things better
that
there's very quickly this the sort of uh
law of diminishing returns sets in when
we're trying deliberately to learn
something it's no longer fresh for our
brain and the brain basically pushes
back whereas if you forget and come back
to it you learn better so but if you
have six seven hours a day there's
nothing wrong with spending some time
reviewing flashcards but if i look at my
own pattern where i consume a lot
of of uh content through listening and
reading acquiring lots and lots of words
if i had to review them all in
flashcards or on lists i would spend my
whole you know i have to decide do i
want to spend my time going through uh
reviewing words say in flashcards or do
i want to spend that time listening and
reading to things of interest so i tend
to do the listening and reading i find
that i acquire words very quickly and i
have an enjoyable time doing it
of course speaking is also helpful
uh because
what you hear the native speakers say
while speaking
is what i call high resonance just as
interesting content is high resonance
and so you notice things
better
if you're engaged in a conversation and
you also notice when you weren't able to
find the words yourself and then you
hear someone else use them so that's
very very good however in my own case i
prefer to delay that
uh speaking situation unless there's a
need if i'm living in the country where
the language is spoken but otherwise i
prefer to delay it until i have
something meaningful to say and can
understand what the other person is
saying so that because otherwise we end
up with a very limited range of language
that we're exposed to like how are you
what's your name what's the weather like
and and so therefore again i prefer to
give myself that significant exposure
through listening and reading quite
confident that the high frequency words
will appear very often the medium
frequency words will appear less often
but i will eventually get them and the
very low frequency words
some mistake and some won't and if
they're that low frequency maybe i don't
really need them but ultimately the
choice is with the learner and my
preference is to study in an enjoyable
way uh if i were in a course somewhere
working five six hours a day having to
write an exam i might take a different
approach but there you have it that's my
take on
how to acquire vocabulary and i will
continue once a week with these
discussions on language learning and if
you're interested please subscribe to my
channel
bye for now